les faibles la famine les crochets comme
c'est foutu c'est fini de tout ça on
s'en fout enfin on fait fi
g fatigant c'est effrayant
on laisse dire pourquoi un lit
la misère est un affront la villa qui ne
se réchauffe pas là elle est là la
misère est un plat 3 baïla lacunes ne se
réchauffe pas
c'est le mâle attendu
à tous les sacrifices
mais qui d'une main tendue
accepter le pit l'assiette
aux manches et le contenu
avec le poche
ils restaurent des pourparlers la
cuillère
c'est pas beaucoup mes
études ont un côté
on sdf au coin des rues un
petit peu pour s'échapper un lampe est
fondante un foyer un grand feu au fond
de son âme on laisse des f au coin des
rues on laisse des f pourquoi les rues
la misère est un plein trois là il al
dakhil se réchauffe
mahila la misère est un plats froids là
il alla qui ne se réchauffe pas et toi
tu vomis tête car tu n'es pas à sec est
temps que tu bois tu remplir à
l'assiette même si pour le prix
découvert tu croit bon de faire un peu
est en fait des coûts sochaux loïc un
géant où tout le monde se croit prêts à
dépenser sa bourse aux casinos à la mise
à
en plâtre et parfois l'argent si du veau
tandis que le four
géant
ou lester fo coin dé lui
impute un coup financier
un gros test pour tout effacer on laisse
tf1 au coin des rues ont l'intérêt
pourquoi les rues
la misère est un plafond là il alla qui
ne se réchauffe pas layana la misère est
simple à 3 l'ariana qui ne se réchauffe
pas ne te crois pas ça l'abri de tous
ces gens compris
tar heels à pourrait qu'un jour couvert
de découvert tu mangeras dans ta
cuillère et tu mordred étant de tave
fourchette en argent tous les bals ces
vidéos on sent pas le déluge à tes pieds
de ben le couteau sous la langue que tu
écouteras la soif et y vendre à
découvert pour que
ton petit toit sans volant
ta couvertures et draps
tu dormiras dans la vue alors tu
découvriras le plat froid
kind of ce show le port
ou leicester au coin des rues un peu
pour une flamme un petit fou ce chat
fait chanter fondante un foyer un grand
feu au fond de son âme on laisse des
femmes au coin des rues on laisse des
points
la misère est un plan 3 leïla qui ne se
réchauffe pas mariën à la misère et sa
place folle là il alla qui ne se
réchauffe pas
voilà c'est ça bayou